the time being 12
30 i'm going to call the session back to
order
we have with us director wadget from the
judicial council
sarah we've been having a little bit of
technology difficulty could you just
into the microphone
say testing testing testing to see if
we've gotten rid of all the static
testing testing testing
okay welcome
your budget is on page 571
i believe i already asked you if we
could post your
documents and mr hoffman was going to
take care of that with
the lovely janet clayman so i think
we're all set to go
so let me turn this over to you welcome
talk to us about your budget thank you
so much madam chair and committee
members
good afternoon i'm sarah blodgett
executive director of the judicial
council
as i think all of you know of the
judicial council's responsibilities have
evolved quite a bit over the years
but our core function continues to be
oversight of the quality and cost
effectiveness of the indigent defense
system in new hampshire the council also
provides for legal and guardian ad litem
services and child protection cases
and it enters into public and private
partnerships
for civil legal aid our agency has three
full-time employees including myself
and the cost to run our agency is about
one percent of our overall budget
and i i apologize for just getting the
handouts to
members um just a few moments ago
but if you take a quick look at our
handouts
the ones that i'll be referring to most
frequently are page three
which is a history of our expenditures
and has highlights to indicate the
additional prioritized needs we'll be
asking for
and then a pie chart on page four
which compares our expenditures in
fiscal 14
so that you can see how our costs have
shifted
not dramatically certainly um but
prosper child protection
um cases have increased and as you can
see on that pie chart on page four
our agency is really a small percentage
of our overall appropriation
many of our expenditures are driven by
unpredictable
and often uncontrollable factors
including the number of child protection
and criminal cases brought by the state
all of the programs that we work with
including the public defender
casa and new hampshire legal assistance
have done an incredible job of providing
crucial services
during the unprecedented challenges of
the pandemic
the state's funding for engineering
defense fulfills the constitutional
requirement
to provide representation for indigent
defendants
as you can see on page four those costs
have gone down slightly
from 89 percent to 85
of our overall budget
in this past fiscal year the number of
new criminal cases
has decreased likely as a result of the
pandemic
and will be
we do expect that as things get back to
normal
that those criminal charges will start
to go back up
to previous levels our child protection
expenditures have increased more than 50
percent
between 2014 and 2020.
again we've seen fewer new cases this
fiscal year
we believe that's a result of the
pandemic children not being in school
not being in after school programs but
we are
anticipating an increase in those cases
again when
things return back to some sense of
normalcy
we also expecting an increase
in the number of child protection cases
brought
based on some of the factors of the
pandemic
increased isolation increased economic
uncertainty
we have seen over time that these tend
to lead to
more instances of alleged abuse or
neglect of children
moving to page 571
of our budget i don't have
have much to say on 1097 our judicial
council budget
so if there are no questions on that
line i'll skip right ahead
to the next page and to the assigned
counsel line
which is right at the bottom 1091.
this line pays for the representation of
indigent defendants and criminal cases
and accuse parents in the child
protection cases
now over the years the percentage of
this overall expenditure has really
increased dramatically for the parent
representation
and in fiscal 20 that accounted for 80
percent
of our overall expenditures for that
year
the governor's budget maintains level
funding at 1.48 million
for fiscal 22 and 23.
based on recent trends we believe that
this will be adequate
but i do want to say that this can be a
very unpredictable line
and factors like the homicide rate
especially if there are co-defendants
you really have a dramatic increase
a public defender can only represent one
defendant in a homicide and so those
costs add up very quickly
i also wanted to let members know that
we're also working with
dhhs to try to access some federal
funding to assist in the parent
representation cross
it's been a very lengthy process joe
ribson and his team have been incredibly
helpful
and we are hopeful that we'll be able to
begin drawing down
some of that money uh in the near future
moving on to 1092
our guardian ad litem line and the
title is doesn't quite encompass
everything that
happens out of this budget line we pay
for
guardianships for incapacitated adults
and minors out of this line but we're
also covering a lot of costs for the
termination of parental rights cases
so the parent attorneys who are handling
that
as well as the private guardians at
lydom
and if you take a look at page three of
our handout
you get a sense of how those costs have
increased really a significant
increase in fiscal 16 we are starting
and i'm sorry that 1091 is the very top
item we're starting to see those costs
level off but if you go down to the
guardian and lighten fund which is
really the next step in the child
protection process
you can see that in fiscal 18 we had a
significant increase
and that's the child protection cases
where there was no reunification
possible
and the state has moved forward to
permanently terminate the parent rights
again we've seen fewer invoices coming
into our office
this fiscal year we know that there have
been
fewer child protection cases brought and
so
this number will be going down a bit um
but we
are asking for an additional prioritized
need
of 241 950
in each year of the biennium
these costs have remained um relatively
stable with regard to the probate
guardianship
cases but we do expect that as things
open up again that the termination costs
may
increase as well
1093 is for the contract attorneys
program
and the contract attorneys are the
statutory backup to the public defender
program
they handle about 14 of the indigent
defense caseload
and all of our contract attorneys are
approved by the indigenous defense
subcommittee
these are reimbursed on a flat fee basis
um and we have seen
not a significant decrease but it was
probably
150 to 200 fewer cases coming into
contract attorneys this fiscal year
compared to last year
the governor's budget has flat funding
for the contract attorney line and we
believe that that will be sufficient for
our needs in the next millennium
defender program 1094.
is by far the biggest percentage of our
budget
the governor has maintained level
funding for the public defender program
at 23 751
832. for both fiscal years 22
and 23. and we believe that that is
sufficient
for what we anticipate will be the
public defender
they are the backbone of our indigent
defense system handling about 85
of the cases statewide there is
um has been a decrease in new cases
during the pandemic
but that is being offset by the amount
of time that cases are remaining open
and i'll give you an example on february
19th of 2020
the public defender had a total of 9522
open cases on that same date just a few
days ago the same date this year they
had
11 967 open cases
this has an impact on the staff attorney
caseloads
by contract with the judicial council
the public defender is supposed to
keep attorneys at or below 70 open
inactive cases because so many cases
have not resolved
they are now facing case loads of over
100 cases
is this because the courts have
basically been closed because of the
pandemic
i believe that it's a combination of
factors
cases are not moving as quickly through
the courts because courts were closed
it's also more difficult to get in touch
with clients
and i think we're seeing an increase in
felony cases
over misdemeanor cases and felony cases
tend to take longer to resolve
do you think you're seeing an increase
in felony cases because of felony first
or cases used to go to the district
court
before the supreme superior courts
i believe that that could be very a
role in what we're seeing the public
defender has statistics showing the
percentage of cases that resolved as
misdemeanors
prior to felonies first in the district
courts
and there were some courts that were
able to resolve cases very quickly is
misdemeanors
i think some of that is the local
knowledge that folks talk about
a prosecutor and a judge who know the
families in their community
and know who is going to be a repeat
offender or who can
really resolve a case with a misdemeanor
resolution
and will then get back on track
thank you
again while we don't expect to see a
sharp increase
in criminal cases like we do with the
child protection cases
we do expect those numbers to increase
and some of the issues that public
defender clients tend to struggle with
mental health diagnosis substance use
issues
those are being exacerbated during the
pandemic as folks are isolated
and maybe not able to get to services
that they would be using
prior to covet um we anticipate
an increased need and also an increase
in the number of people who qualify for
a public defender
in the next diamond
non-consulate services are all of the
experts transcriptionists translators
that the court has approved in a
criminal case the judge has made a
determination that those are necessary
services for a constitutionally adequate
representation of defense now those
cases have
those costs rather have increased quite
a bit
over the past several years and again
i'll just point you to page three of our
handout
services other than council is the last
item
and you can see that we have had a
significant increase
we really have exceeded 1.2 million
dollars
for the last four fiscal years
we are seeing fewer invoices right now
again a result of the pandemic but we do
have an additional prioritized need
request
for this line it is 483
129 for fiscal 22
and a little less 467
966 for fiscal 23.
once the court has made a determination
that
a service is necessary the judicial
council was obligated to pay for that
service
moving along to new hampshire legal
assistance
i think as many of you know new
hampshire legal assistance
provides for civil legal needs around
the state
while the public defender represents
individuals facing criminal charges
nhla represents individuals facing civil
legal challenges
such as unlawful evictions foreclosures
or domestic abuse and the council serves
as the pass-through for the state's
commitment to the civil legal needs of
indigent residents the governor's budget
maintains level funding at 1.5 million
due in part to the increase in state
funding that we
first saw in this biennium nhla
has been able to maintain at least three
advocates
in all five of its offices including the
north country office in berlin
new hampshire legal assistance is on the
front lines of cases that have been
and will continue to be impacted by the
pandemic
that includes housing relief employment
security
and protection from domestic violence
matters all areas that the state has
prioritized through its code relief
initiatives
pandemic has certainly underscored the
importance of assisting people with
these basic needs
new hampshire legal assistance's
response to the pandemic
has been nimble and effective they
created the crisis response fellowship
a public-private partnership that
maximized their cares act funding
to assist clients with housing and
unemployment issues
they have been conducting remote
hearings and client meetings
which is obviously not going to be
appropriate for all clients
some people need face-to-face
communication or don't have access to
sufficient broadband but when that is
enough this allows nhla to assign cases
based on the need instead of the
advocate availability in a certain
geographic
area they've also taken this time to
put together some dynamic programming
online
they have hosted a number of webinars on
eviction processes and have had very
good turnout
folks from all over the state can tune
into the webinar
they can ask general questions they're
not given specific legal advice
but they are able to get educated and
get some practical information
about the eviction process and as all of
you know that has
been really updated on a regular basis
because of some of the changes coming
out of
dc
right oh yes represent vmware for a
question
followed by represent patch excuse me
representative
are these webinars reported
i believe that they are um i will
double check with sarah mats and dustin
she
and um folks from the public defender
and casa
i believe are participating on the zoom
meeting
there are specific questions for them
but i believe that they're going to
start making those available
to folks who weren't able to be at the
original
event thank you represent patch
think you're muted
unmuted i muted myself i'm sorry um
do you handle all types of cases or
there are some civil cases that you do
not
handle within the judicial council
that's right the judicial council so
our agency doesn't provide any direct
representation
we work with these different programs or
pay individual attorneys
so the public defender handles the
criminal side
of things where somebody is facing
charges has been arrested
then we pay for certain representation
in child protection cases which are also
civil proceedings
new hampshire legal assistance provides
for the civil
legal needs of the poor people in this
state so that could be
domestic violence eviction or
foreclosure
but the public defender program
statutorily is prohibited
from doing anything other than criminal
representation
thank you thank you for the question
civil legal services are a crucial
component of many of the most important
challenges
faced by our state right now keeping
people in their homes
making sure they maintain their income
making sure that their utilities stay
on these are essential services to meet
the needs of veterans
the needs of people facing mental health
crises and the needs of people with
substance use disorders
they're also essential to the state's
ongoing management of the pandemic and
economic fallout
the judicial council also enters into a
contract with
casa to provide guardian ad litem
services in the child protection cases
and the governor's budget maintains
level funding for casa
at nine hundred twenty six thousand five
hundred fifty dollars for each year of
the biennium
casa really is the gold standard for
guardian ad litem services
their volunteer advocates receive
extensive training
and supervision required
moment
excuse me representative ober this is
mike hoffman
i think uh sarah's microphone just died
let's see
hello i'll go see if i can find the
fellas to get it working
passing it to her let's see if that
works
like yes i'm
i'm here
over here
so
that technology is really great when it
works
yes i can hear you
can you hear me
i'm having trouble hearing you now our
representative over
representative ober this is robert from
berlin i just
zoomed in got back from littleton
congratulations i'm kidding okay thank
you
hold on i did get stopped for speeding
because i wanted to make it here
but no ticket i'm all set
mike can you hear sarah she's saying
testing
i can hear you representative over but
not uh
not sarah
yep i can hear you scott
[Music]
that sounds good
okay scott whatever you did magically
with those fingers we promise not to
touch anything
[Music]
represent waltz did you have a question
or were you trying to tell us
we you couldn't hear
i was just trying to address the silence
so thank you that's why i took my hand
down
when mike start again that was adequate
thank you okay thank you
um sarah can you continue please
thank you um so i'm sorry i was talking
about our
appropriation for casa and telling you a
bit about the extraordinary work that
their advocates are doing
i'll just i'll briefly back up to
say again that in fiscal 20 casa
spent over 77 000 hours and drove over
500 000
miles on their cases and if we had had
to pay for that through the private
guardian ad advice
program it would have cost well over 4.5
million
because of the urgent nature of these
cases the courts have prioritized them
throughout the pandemic
the number of new cases coming in has
decreased between the stuff
but the cases that are pending are still
moving through
everybody is doing what needs to be done
to keep these on track
and when it was clear that in-person
visits were not possible
in all cases casa quickly pivoted
to require their advocates to have eyes
on their skills
at least once
or face time but to ensure that somebody
was actually seeing these foods
during the tendency of the case and
during the
first half of this fiscal year casas
actually had
more contact with their children because
they understand the
dangers of the isolation that we've all
been under and they have really gone
above and beyond
they estimate that now about 46 of cases
are happening in person
advocates get vaccinated but that number
is fluid and if there's an outbreak at a
certain facility
then the visits may have to go back to
the
eyes on only
pandemic they're conducting online
information sessions where they're able
to reach a
large variety of a number of folks
across the state
they're doing their training for new
advocates remotely
and those are some efficiencies that
casa intends to bring forward even after
the pandemic is
a distant memory for all of us
the last uh i want to talk about is the
non-casa guardians as light on and this
is another
area where we are seeking an additional
prioritized need
150 000 a year for each year of the
biennium
the governor's budget maintains level
funding for this accounting unit
but as you can see if you take another
look again on page three of our handout
that these costs have been
in excess of three hundred thousand
dollars for the past
two fiscal years private guardians that
light up
only take a case if a casa is
unavailable
they're paid an hourly reimbursement
rate of 60
and our expenditures are down again for
this
accounting unit right now but we do
expect that we will need the additional
funding to meet the need going forward
i don't have any other comments right
now but i'm
happy to take questions from the
committee and i certainly appreciate
everyone's time
and patience with i guess i just have
bad technology luck wherever i go so
thank you
we always appreciate you coming and bad
technology luck is it really a thing it
just sometimes happens in this room
or in any other room anybody have a
question representative wishman
oh i'm sorry hold on while we pass the
mic back and forth
oh now it's caught between tables
off the top of my head but i had to go
back to fiscal
several times and the lines that we had
to go back
for were services other than council and
the private guardians of items
and also the probate guardian as light
online
you can see our our actual
expenditures in those areas
have been exceeded what we were
originally appropriated i now think that
given the decrease in the assigned
council costs
that that is a line that we will likely
not need to go back for
in the next
sarah and your adjusted authors for 2021
does that include all the money
additional money you've got it this one
hi representative over it's mike again i
think we lost sarah again
oh i just how's that
um in and out we'll let mike really
close to you and don't look down
anything hold the
paper up there you go thank you
the budget that you're looking at the
adjusted authorized
for fiscal 20 does include what we
received when we went back
for additional funding okay all right
so representation sorry you had a second
question
for a third question more questions
do that mind if i ask you what yourself
and i was due for an increase this past
summer
but i did not take them because of the
economic reality space in my state
additional questions by anyone on the
committee
thank you um we're still sarah's mike
and
and peter's mike was cutting in and out
so i just want to clarify a couple
things because i wasn't hearing at all
so i'm just trying to get the number
that
um would include her additional requests
on page three
do we have that number or does the is
the number in our binder include that
number
or how do we know how much to fund her
that would include the additional
request she has listed on paid three
page three
she brought page three with her when she
came today
yeah she did take it down to janet so it
could be distributed
the additional total amount represent
walls
for fiscal year 2022 and that includes
four lines it would be 880 000.
834 000.
23 goes up to 865
plus dollars so i added those together
and i get 1.746478
and my question is do we need to take
that 1.7
million and add it to the amount and our
binder to get an
adequate budget for her
this is i would say given what she's
said to us sarah if i miss phrase what i
think you said
speak right up and tell me why i'm wrong
but she's
said she's given it her best estimate
knowing the courts have not been meeting
knowing some of the cases have been off
plus the fact
that director ribson over at hhs has
started a new program
that hopefully will include her with
some funding
i close to understanding what you said
overall
yes that's correct and so the the three
accounting units that i
anticipate needing additional
appropriation for
are the services other than council
[Music]
the non-casa guardians of leiden
and our gal fund which is really probate
and termination of parental rights costs
represent walls additional questions or
further clarification
now i'm just trying to get a handle on
the dollar amount for this
and that's all and i just so if we're
going to approve this i just wanted to
have some idea what it is
that we need to be adding in in addition
to
what's in the binder i don't think given
director bridget's number will be
approving or not approving this today we
should get revenue estimates for house
ways and means
on the 25th and anything that needs to
have changes
or potentially have changes anything
that uses general fund dollars
we're probably not going to go forward
with today
okay thank you very much well even when
we go forward i still want
would like to have a solid number as to
i mean is the 1.746 million the correct
number or is it a different number
it's her best estimate today at the time
where she is with the request she has
is that correct that's correct and i
i'm sorry i don't have the total for
those two years
i can tell you that the total of
additional prioritized needs
is on page three of our handout for
fiscal 22
it's 880 thousand eight into thirty four
dollars
and it is a bit less in the next year at
eight hundred sixty five thousand six
hundred forty four dollars thank you
those are the numbers i used i just
added them together
so that's that we're on the state we're
talking the same thing
thank you
any additional questions for the
director
see none sarah thank you for coming
thank you for the thorough
presentation thank you for bringing
handouts to us today
we are not taking a position on your
budget today
obviously we can't when we don't have
ways in these revenue estimates
we may at some time need to have you
back but it will be a shorter
conversation
great thank you so much members i
appreciate your time
okay committee members we are going to
be in recess
until 1 30 when we had the new hampshire
retirement system coming
and i believe this is um their
director's last day of work i think he's
retiring
so we may be the last last time we see
him so
we will recess until 1 30. tracy will
you please
turn off our sound and
chairman orba this is uh representative
are you there
robert i think they turned everything
off okay because i don't know where
we're at
and do you know if we have written
testimony forever
we do actually if you look around three
something yesterday um
janet sent out the stuff on the
retirement system it's in our email
okay which one is that
there's quite a few handouts here yeah i
know hang on let me just go back to
yesterday and see if i can